j'ai reçu une lettre d' excuses de
l'hôpital dans lequel j'ai accouché
j'ai eu un déclenchement on n'a pas
prévenu vous déclenchez on a déclenché
mais en fait on a oublié dans une pièce
pendant plusieurs heures quand on est
revenus la tête était en train de sortir
et puis ensuite j'ai eu d'autres choses
que je fais pas forcément raconter mais
qui sont vraiment de l'ordre de la
boucherie la question de l'accouchement
et la manière dont les femmes vivent
leur accouchement c'est une question qui
était extrêmement tabou et donc je me
suis aperçu que c'était un sujet
important majeur qui concernait beaucoup
de femmes mais qui n'avaient jamais été
traités par les pouvoirs publics étaient
en dessous des radars
[Musique]
le terme du earth obstétricales il est
encore floue pour pas mal pour pas mal
de monde et puis il ya toujours quoi
encore il me semble une forme de déni ou
de méfiance vous avez des femmes qui qui
témoignent par rapport à tous les
témoignages qui est sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya eu certes un gynéco qui
ont traité un peu sa part le mépris en
disant que bon elle n'avait pas compris
leur accouchement que l'accouchement
était violent par essence qu'elle
n'avait pas compris et que c'était
finalement une vue de l'esprit
alors ces femmes là on le voit bien dans
le film elles sont pour certaines où
elles ont été en état de stress post
traumatique parfois pendant deux ans
voire plus donc non c'était pas une vue
de l'esprit ce qu'elles ont vécu les a
profondément traumatisées elles ont aidé
c'est que des séquelles psychiques
physiques etc
à un moment elle a posé les forceps je
crois que là oui je pense que tout le
monde à peu près compris à quel point il
y avait pas de péril vol parce que en
fait ça a donné et commencent à les
mettre chez jours de douleurs j'ai gens
sautent au plafond en fait donc l'équipe
me saute dessus pour m'attraper les gens
qui les maintiennent en fête avec leurs
avants bras à travers des étriers très
bonne idée plutôt d'arrêter l'extraction
on continue les mecs maintient l'idée du
siècle
sachant que pour effectivement la sage
femme n'y a pas d'anomalie du rythme et
pas de manitobains pas d'urgence à là ma
fille n'était pas en train de mourir
[Musique]
il ya cette idée quand même que en tant
que femme on est censé avoir intériorisé
la douleur c'est censé être quelque
chose d'habituel de commun chez nous on
est censé en baver pendant les règles
c'est on voit bien d'ailleurs que dans
le traitement de l'endométriose bacon
certaines femmes arrivent on voit leurs
généraux et dj anormalement bas les
bains ont dit oui bon pas vous avez vos
règles quoi en gros on a intégré l'idée
que les rapports sexuels parfois il
était douloureux que la pénétration été
douloureuse on a intégré l'idée qu'on
était censé un chien pendant
l'accouchement que d'autres façons
c'était presque une fatalité tu
enfanteras dans la douleur enfin voilà
c'est la prophétie biblique on est censé
en baver sauf que n'ont pas forcément et
outre l'acte en lui-même tout ce qui se
passe à un accouchement qui peut se
compliquer terrain contre le fait que
l'accouchement bon soit il est souvent
tout de même douloureux il y avait 7 6
il ya certains actes par exemple qui
sont faits sans anesthésie il ya eu des
histoires de césariennes avis finaux qui
nous ont été rapportés beaucoup
d'histoires de d'épisiotomie à vif de
suture à ville de révision utérine à vif
et c'est absolument inconcevable dans
n'importe quel autre service de
l'hôpital un homme qui arrive qui chez
pas une doit se faire recoudre on va pas
le recoudre à vif
on va lui faire pour le moindre truc le
une anesthésie quelqu'un qui arrive même
en situation d'urgence absolue
on va quand même l'anesthésié avant de
lui offrir le hobbit si c'est nécessaire
donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment cette
idée chez les femmes qui vont accoucher
mais aussi chez certains soignants que
de toute façon puisque l'accouchement
c'est violent par essence et ben c'est
comme ça voilà et on va pas faire en
sorte d'améliorer les choses ce qui est
important dans toute cette histoire
c'est la notion de choix et la notion de
consentement
en fait il n'ya pas d'accouchement
réussi on peut pas dire un accouchement
réussi simplement sans péridurale avec
une mise au sein immédiate et cetera
derrière c'est passé un accouchement
réussi un accouchement réussi c'est un
accouchement qui s'est bien passé ou les
tout était consentie où tout a été fait
en accord
et où surtout maman et bébé vont bien
mais je parle pas juste d'un point de
vue physique ou et tout le monde va bien
physiquement psychiquement et où le lien
derrière va pouvoir se construire
[Musique]
c'est bien gentil de dire les
gynécologues ne sont pas gentils on m'a
mal accueillis on n'était pas gentil
avec moi mais sachez que quand un
gynécologue a fait cinq-six la reine
dans sa nuit il ya du brancardier
lui-même les patientes pascal personne
pour le faire il peut lui-même se sentir
mal traités et de fait devenir
maltraitant donc la première chose si on
veut respecter les femmes et c'est notre
métier à nous les gynécologues de faire
tout ce qu'on peut pour que les femmes
soient bien et pour leur santé
s'améliore
c'est de les faire accoucher être opéré
et être soignés dans des endroits qui
ont les moyens de les soigner
quand j'étais en immersion maternité
autant les sages pas bon et les aides
soignants qu'on oublie souvent ont
accepté de participer au film autant les
gynécos ne voulait même pas m'adresser
la parole et je vous passe en plus des
quelques remarques sexistes qui m'ont
été rapportés même par rapport aux je
dirai à mon passé professionnel
donc on se dit si des professionnels de
santé qui travaillent sur les questions
d'un team de génitalité de sexualité
peuvent se permettre d'apporter des
jugements sur la sexualité rennes ou
prétendus de la personne qu'ils ont face
à face à savoir moi même ce jour là si
ça pousse quand même ça pose quand même
problème les toute une génération de
jeunes soignants qui a qui ont fini qui
sont un peu plus conscientisés sur ces
questions là et qu'ils n'ont pas envie
d'avoir de de position de supériorité la
position du sachant ou vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de la patiente
donc moi j'ai quand même l'impression
que ça bouge mais il aura fallu passer
par une phase d'abord où on aura
décrédibiliser mépriser les témoignages
de ces femmes ou les zorra traiter
d'affabulatrice d'hystérique on leur a
dit qu'elle était c'était des femmes
fragiles îles etc voilà il aura fallu
passer par cette phase là quand même
pour enfin commencer à évoluer